Monica is in Newark New Jersey hey
Monica welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I'm doing just fine how you doing Dave
better than I deserve
how can I help Dave so currently my
boyfriend and I it was a weekly I mean
we just recently got engaged so we're
hoping to get married within the next
two years and so I mean we live
justified in New York City and
personally I feel we should live
together before we get married just
because I feel we need to kind of feel
out just kind of everything before we
actually get married and I wasn't to a
whole lot of your podcasts about the
four actual like actual like tenants
about why you should agree on before you
get married a nuclei about three of them
feeling when we should actually work on
as our in-laws and my own actual
question is he is about to come into a
big inheritance of about 300,000 from a
and a core case that he's working on
because he was actually hit by a
distracted driver last year he was on a
motorcycle and he was hit by a teenage
unfortunately you hit by a teenage girl
who was on her cell phone yeah so he's
about to get his lawyer set a minimum of
three hundred thousand and what he wants
to do with it is pay off all of our debt
which I have a hundred thousand student
loans and he has 20 thousand in the car
and that's all that we owe and he wants
to pay that off and then start looking
forward to our wedding and kind of our
life together but personally I I would
personally rather look to rent together
what is your question for me my question
is should we go into this mortgage
because he wants to purchase an actual
property you should never buy a house
with somebody you're not married to
under any circumstances ever and
husbands are not shoes you don't try
them on before you buy them
that's not how it works
all the data in all the marriage
research shows that people who do not
live together prior to marriage have a
higher probability of success in their
marriage tons of research out there to
back that up it's not somebody somebody
something somebody just made up and so
you don't combine finances
you don't buy houses with your roommate
and and I wouldn't have a roommate until
I was married you called me an ass so
you don't get my opinion that's the
thing and I just want what's good for
you I mean here's the thing if how old
are you today when we visit the 46 year
old version of you if she could talk to
the 26 year old version of you she would
tell you the same thing I'm telling you
right now date get engaged don't wait
two years get married quick get married
if you're going to get married but don't
get married until we're in agreement on
those four areas money in-laws kids and
religion do some pre marriage counseling
with a local pastor or a pre-marriage or
our marriage counselor something like
that do all of that and you increase
your probability of success financially
relationally in your marriage that's
what I would do but I'm just an old guy